foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory due to all of the demand
in the comment section today we're going
to be discussing rubius Hagrid played by
the late and great Robbie Coltrane for
those unaware Robbie Coltrane who
famously played Ruby's Hagrid and
tragically passed recently at the age of
72 Coltrane who've been fighting poor
health for the last couple of years
finally died in hospital near his home
in Scotland the last time Coltrane
appeared on camera was this year during
the 20th Harry Potter anniversary
special returned to Hogwarts and it was
here that he reassured fans that though
he may not be around forever Hagrid
isn't going anywhere forever cemented in
film and in the hearts of millions upon
millions of Hagrid fans worldwide a few
different videos were requested on The
Lovable half giant ranging from 10 best
things about Hagrid to things we don't
know about Hagrid but I decided to land
on the latter so that I can cover some
aspects of Hagrid's character that
casual fans may not have ever known
let's get into it 10. his Hogwarts house
though there has been much speculation
over the years and a considerable number
of theories it turns out that rather
unsurprisingly Hagrid was a part of
Gryffindor given Hagrid's bravery
kindness and nobility this probably
isn't much of a shock while his house is
not revealed in the books it is revealed
in an article published on Wizarding
World that makes this little factoid
Canon do you share a house with Hagrid
9. based on a real person the list of
Harry Potter characters inspired by real
people is lengthy including Severus
Snape Harry Potter Ron Weasley and even
gilderoy Lockhart to name a few so it
shouldn't come as a surprise to you that
just like these other characters Hagrid
2 was based on a real person a biker to
be precise in Harry Potter page to
screen the complete filmmaking Journey
according to Robbie Coltrane the
character was modeled on a real biker
Coltrane said that JK Rowling told him
that Hagrid was based on Hell's Angels
she knew in the west country he was just
huge and terrifying Coltrane recalled
rolling telling him and then he would
sit down and talk about his garden and
how his petunias had been very bad that
year eight larger plans for Hagrid in
the beginning of the Philosopher's Stone
we see hanker delivering an infant Harry
Potter to the dursley Residence at
privet drive it was an emotional scene
as the soft lovable half giant could
barely contain himself as he released
Harry from his grasp but what many may
not know is that this scene both
protected Hagrid's character and set the
stage for a similar scene in the Deathly
Hallows in an interview JK Rowling
revealed that she had always planned for
Hagrid to carry Harry's seemingly
lifeless body out of the Forbidden
Forest during the Battle of Hogwarts she
she also explained that Hagrid carrying
Harry at the end was symbolic because it
mimicked Hagrid carrying baby Harry in
the first book apparently this image
kept him safe and ensured that Hagrid
was kept around for future books 7.
dementor's meal in the Chamber of
Secrets Hagrid is wrongfully sent to
Azkaban after being accused of reopening
the Chamber of Secrets of course Hagrid
was not responsible in the slightest but
that didn't stop him from being
Cornelius fudge's scapegoat Azkaban
destroys a lot of its prisoners it ages
them wears them down strips them of
their vitality and that's largely due to
the presence of its prison guards the
Dementors with that said it's worth
noting that Hagrid was able to keep his
sanity in check at the prison despite
only being there a brief period
Apparently after Hagrid was released
from Azkaban the Dementors nearly
revolted because they had lost a good
food source someone with strong emotions
that they can feed on 6. importer in the
Harry Potter story there are all sorts
of interesting creatures roaming around
but quite often I found myself thinking
why are so many of these creatures
within proximity to Hogwarts yes the
Forbidden Forest is close to the school
but it's even remarked in the books that
some of these creatures are
exceptionally rare creatures like
thestrals and acromantulas as it turns
out Hagrid is the one responsible for
bringing both thestrals and acromantulas
to the UK vestrals are extremely rare
wild creatures that the ministry of
magic considers to be dangerous because
of their link to death Hagrid tamed one
male and five female thestrals to bring
to Hogwarts who spawned an entire herd
the Hogwarts thestrals are the only hand
to Ever Be Tamed and used as pants in
all of England and no other cases are
known around the world neither Hagrid is
also responsible for bringing
acromantula to England as the species is
native to Borneo Hagrid released aragog
into the forest before snagging a female
acromantula named Mosaic aragog and
mosaic's resulting colony is the only
one to exist in England 5. his weakness
given that Hagrid was the care of
magical creatures professor and showed
an affinity for magical creatures on par
with famed magic zoologist newt's
Commander you may be surprised to hear
that Hagrid's only weakness is a tiny
pet you may have heard of I can't in the
philosopher stone Hagrid tells Harry
that he don't like cats because they
make him sneeze which is why he chose to
buy Harry an owl Hedwig for his birthday
present 4. stunted magic magical powers
aren't revealed in a magical child until
they are provoked out of them sometimes
remaining dormant for a considerable
amount of time in Hagrid's case this was
the reality as his powers didn't truly
manifest until after he'd received his
Hogwarts letter and purchased his first
one from ollivanders Hagrid simply never
had an incident in his childhood where
his emotions were heightened and for
this reason his powers didn't manifest
3. he can't cast this spell in the Harry
Potter story casting the Patronus charm
seems to be a rite of passage a
signifier that to witch or wizard has
truly honed his or her magical abilities
the Patronus charm is a positive energy
force a physical representation of Hope
happiness survival and Purity it's the
primary defense that a witch or wizard
might use against Dementors as because
the Patronus does not feel despair or
hopelessness the Dementors are repelled
by its presence but what may surprise
you is that Hagrid can't cast a Patronus
in a q a with Harry Potter fans on
Twitter JK Rowling was quizzed what
Hagrid's Patronus would be in reply she
wrote Hagrid couldn't produce a Patronus
it's a very difficult spell provided
that the Patronus in corporeal form
assumes the shape of an animal Guardian
it's surprising that Hagrid doesn't have
one two where his name came from
Hagrid's full name is rubius Hagrid and
just like many of the other characters
in the story his name actually has a lot
of depth he wasn't named haphazardly
Hagrid is a big drinker who's regularly
seen by Harry to indulge in visits to
the pub and even getting inebriated his
name alludes to his personality trait
because rubius is related to the word
Ruddy which means reddish and is
apparent on someone who drinks a lot 1.
his first wand it seems strange that for
as long as we've known Hagrid he's held
an umbrella in place of a wand and while
Hagrid's original one is inside of this
umbrella it was once a fully functioning
magical item in its own right Hagrid's
first wand free umbrella was a 16-inch
Oak one rather bendy with an unknown
core material those with Oak ones
usually have an affinity with the magic
of the natural world a bendy wand
signifies a high level of adaptability
in his personality and the length of his
wand is representative of his large
stature and enormous personality and
that's it for this video thank you for
joining me in honoring the late in great
Robbie Coltrane by dissecting his iconic
character until next time remember
what's coming will come and we'll meet
it when it does